i'm pleased to see that our leading and
lagging indicators have declined or
remained stable
on february 8th our positivity rate for
lab confirmed pcr tests was around 30
percent today it is down to 20.5 percent
one month ago there were sixteen hundred
and sixty four people in hospital with
covet 19 including 134 in intensive care
today there are
1 106 and 77 people respectively
new daily admissions have dropped almost
every day for over a month since they
peaked on february 7th
all this data combined with high levels
of vaccine protection in alberta
confirms that it was the right time to
transition our response to covet 19.
over the course of the last few weeks we
have slowly returned to a more normal
way of life as omicron transmission has
decreased and the pressure on our health
system has eased but as we ease
restrictions and move forward together
we cannot ignore the strain that covet
19 has placed on our health care system
we must build our system capacity to
ensure that albertans continue to get
the high quality care they need and that
they deserve
that's why we're investing 300 million
over three years to add icu capacity
this includes allocating 100 million for
up to 50 new permanent icu beds this
year
and another hundred million in each of
the following two years to keep those
beds operational
these new icu beds will be distributed
in all ahs zones across the province
with further details on locations
currently being developed
our goal is to ensure maximum
flexibility so the system can surge as
needed and resources can be redeployed
to support other parts of the health
system when icus are not facing
pressures
the pandemic has shown us that we need
more permanent beds more staff and more
resiliency within our system so we can
be fully prepared for any future health
crisis
we expect them to come online in the
coming months and ahs is working on
plans to recruit and train the necessary
staff to operate these new beds
having the staff to take action in icus
and at healthcare facilities across
alberta is a top priority
and that is one of the reasons why today
i have directed ahs
to rescind its immunization of workers
for covet 19 policy effective march 10th
at 4 pm
this directive covers employees of ahs
its subsidiaries and covenant health
employees members of the medical and
midwifery staff
students and instructors volunteers and
applicable contracted service providers
including those working on ahs sites and
separate providers under contract
this change is in line with policies in
other jurisdictions including manitoba
and quebec
as of 4 pm tomorrow ahs will no longer
require currently unvaccinated employees
to do mandatory rapid testing
employees on a leave of absence due to
immunization status should work with
their managers to determine their return
date
i know that a draft copy of this
directive was leaked last week however i
want to reiterate that the current
directive signed off and released today
with an effective date of march 10th at
4 pm
is what will be implemented
when this immunization policy was
implemented late last year
it was to protect patients healthcare
workers and the public during a time of
record transmission and an incredibly
severe wave of delta
and at that time we committed to
reviewing the policy by march 31st 2022
fortunately now
we are at the tail end of the omicron
wave and with our high vaccination rates
we're in a very different situation
we're extremely grateful to all those
workers who chose to get immunized this
was essential over the last year to
protect themselves their patients and
our health care system
i know hs continues to recommend covet
19 immunization to all its staff and
will continue to work with those
who who choose not to get immunized to
address their concerns
answer their questions and educate them
about the importance of immunization and
vaccine effectiveness
outside of the health system we continue
to follow the evidence to make sure
albertans are protected by vaccines
including additional doses as necessary
that's why following the recommendation
of the alberta advisory committee on
immunization i'm pleased to announce
that beginning march 14th alberta youth
age 12 to 17 who have had their second
dose at least five months ago will be
able to receive a third dose
i know this is welcome news for many
parents guardians and youth
dr hinshaw will provide more details on
when and where appointments will be
available
as you know we are also in the middle of
a two-week effort at ahs clinics to get
more children between the ages of 5 and
11 vaccinated
to make it easier for parents and
guardians to get their kids immunized
clinics across the province are
providing pediatric doses on a walk-in
basis and extending clinic hours
in the first week more than 6500 first
and second doses have been administered
this is great news for young albertans
their families and our communities
we'll continue to work to increase
boosters in the general population and
make pediatric vaccines available for
families who choose to get them for
their children
now if you have questions about a coven
19 vaccine and whether or not it's right
for you
or someone you love please speak to a
health professional like a family doctor
or pharmacist or call 811 health link
they can answer your questions and give
you accurate information
so thank you and i now like to invite dr
hinshaw to the podium
thank you minister and good afternoon
everyone
two years ago today i shared the news
that we had our first officially
confirmed case of covet 19 in alberta
and that we had a total of four
presumptive cases
at that time we had no vaccines we had
no antivirals and we still had much to
learn about the virus
we've come a very long way since then
what we've seen over the past two years
is extraordinary
the speed of identification and sharing
of new information on this virus has
been without precedent
along with others around the globe we
have continually used the latest
research and findings to translate into
best practices
to protect us from the worst impacts of
a virus the world had never seen before
i know that we will continue to adapt as
we transition into this next stage
change is difficult
it is especially difficult when there is
no single right answer to the challenges
we face
we no longer need to respond to covet as
the biggest health threat we
collectively face and yet we still need
to mitigate its direct impacts
this might seem contradictory and this
is part of why finding our way forward
is so hard
we need to be able to hold two realities
at the same time
one is that covid is still a threat to
take seriously and the other is that the
covid population risk has been reduced
and we can move to seeing covid as one
risk among many one we cannot fully
eliminate but that we can manage
given the tension between these two
realities one of the most important
tools in our way forward
is dialogue and understanding different
perspectives
i ask that all of us continue to do our
best to be gentle with ourselves and
with others as we go through this
transition
it's inevitable that we will have
difficult days and we will also have
good ones
as we have throughout the last two years
we can strengthen the relationships in
our communities to help us all get
through
turning to today's update over the last
24 hours we have identified 467 new
cases of covet 19 and completed about 2
200 pcr tests
our positivity rate is 20.5 percent
as the minister mentioned there are
currently a total of 1 106 people with
covet 19 in hospital
including 77 in the icu
sadly seven new deaths were reported to
alberta health over the last 24 hours
my condolences go to the family and
friends of these albertans and to anyone
who's experienced a loss from any cause
these deaths remind us of the reality i
mentioned earlier that the virus is
still with us and can pose a serious
threat for albertans who aren't
vaccinated or who have additional risk
factors
that's why even as we move forward with
easing restrictions we are being
cautious in high risk settings and
leaving protections in place to help
protect vulnerable albertans
this includes continued mandatory
masking in all continuing care
facilities acute care settings and on
public transit
as provinces across the country and
jurisdictions around the world begin
working towards an endemic approach to
covet many adjustments are needed
after two years of mandatory public
health measures and fundamental changes
to the way we have lived worked and
socialized this will not be easy for all
of us
especially for those who may have an
increased risk of serious outcomes from
the virus
we need to assess the coveted risk for
ourselves and our families and make the
best decisions possible for our unique
circumstances
it's critical that we respect the
choices that people make and show
patience and tolerance to those who are
making different choices than we make
for ourselves
as we're considering how to best protect
ourselves and our families
one finding that has stayed solid is
that vaccines are highly effective at
preventing severe outcomes
currently over 3.35 million albertans or
more than 86 percent of everyone over
the age of 12
have received two doses of covid19
vaccine while close to 1.6 million have
gotten their booster dose
it is because so many albertans have
willingly rolled up their sleeves to get
the vaccine that we are at this point
today
long after restrictions are lifted
vaccination against covid19 will
continue to be an important part of
albertans health and well-being
that's because we know that vaccine
remains the single most effective way to
prevent loss of life hospitalization and
severe outcomes from covert 19.
this reality makes today's announcement
about booster doses available for all
youth between the ages of 12 and 17 an
important one for many alberta families
while the risk of severe outcomes for
these youth is low compared to the those
in older age categories or for youth who
have health risk factors
the alberta advisory committee on
immunization has recommended offering
boosters as an option for this age group
to help increase their level of
protection against covet
this is in line with guidance in other
jurisdictions including bc ontario
saskatchewan and quebec
where boosters are being offered to
those between the ages of 12 and 17.
i know many alberta youth and parents
have wondered when they would be
eligible for additional protection
against omicron
especially as restrictions on youth
activities and schooling are coming to
an end third dose appointments for those
aged 12 to 17 will begin on march 14th
and can be booked immediately through
the alberta vaccine booking system or by
calling healthlink at 811.
these booster doses will be administered
at ahs clinics and participating
pharmacies province-wide
for most adolescents without risk
factors two doses still offers good
protection against severe outcomes
however we know that some in this age
group live with high risk household
members or may have other factors that
make this third dose important as an
added layer of protection
if you have questions about whether or
not a third dose is the right choice for
your child
please talk to a health care
professional
i also want to mention updated guidance
released by the national advisory
committee on immunization last month
related to the time period between
infection and receiving vaccine
it is now recommended to wait eight
weeks after covet infection before
beginning or completing a primary series
of vaccine
and to wait three months after infection
before getting a booster dose
for those who have already received
vaccine at a shorter time interval
there is no need for concern
this new recommendation simply gives
guidance on what provides a good balance
of benefit at a population level and is
one factor to take into consideration as
you talk to your health care
professional about what is right for you
and your family thank you and we're
happy to take questions
thanks dr hanchana and minister kopping
no reporters here in the room with us
but a couple on the phone so operator
will go to the first caller please
thank you matt woodman ctv
hi there my first question is for dr
hinshaw there is a divide between the
province and the city of edmonton when
it comes to masking in public places i
was curious if the city of edmonton came
to you and asked her your recommendation
whether to keep masking or to drop it
what would you tell them yes or no
as you'll recall a few weeks ago i made
the statement which i still believe that
masking is a prudent public health
measure and at the same time the policy
rules around masking
are difficult ones that have to be made
by weighing advantages and disadvantages
so it's critical that we work with local
partners as we're considering uh how to
respond to covid and how local partners
are engaged and how we work with them
those are policy decisions that are made
by elected officials
dr angel follow up matt
i do this one is for the health minister
uh minister kaufman is there any plans
to bring back pcr testing for the
general population
thanks for the thanks for the question
there's no plans to bring back pcr uh
testing for the general population at
this time
uh but this is similar approach that's
being taken across the uh across the
country um you know we are focusing our
resources on on pcr testing for you know
high-risk individuals and uh and
high-risk locations uh but given that
the uh we're coming down the other side
of uh omicron and moving into endemic
phase we don't see we don't see the need
to actually uh open up pcr testing uh
for right now uh but then again we'll
continue to watch the the numbers what
uh what the next wave may bring and and
and we are maintaining a core amount of
uh capacity to be able to do pcr testing
for the future
thanks minister we had just two outlets
on the line to start with so we'll go to
the second one which will be our last
one for the day
lauren pullen global calgary
hi there thanks for taking my question
this afternoon uh my first one is for dr
henshaw uh we've heard some messaging in
the past few weeks here about learning
to live with cobit and even today you
spoke about the two realities are you
able to provide a bit more insight and
break down what that practically means
for for most albertans is that just
about shifting back to normal life
pre-pandemic or what is your advice on
learning to live with covet including
for the vulnerable and
immuno-compromised in our profits
it's a good question and it really
underscores the fact that there is no
single reality about living with covid
so for those who have an immune
compromising condition
for those who are at higher risk of
severe outcomes there is a need to
continue to take added layers of
precaution
and
what learning to live with kovid means
for us collectively i believe means
again understanding that
respecting what
other people's
context
means and the additional precautions
that they may need to take to keep
themselves safe
while we're able to have discussions
about the
trade-offs that are
are present
certainly we we all know that
the
precautions and the public health
measures that we've needed to take
collectively over the past few years
have had their own impacts on health
so i think learning to live with kovid
means recognizing that we won't
eliminate it that there will continue to
be a level of transmission that will
come and go over time
we will continue to monitor and if there
are new variants that cause more severe
outcomes we need to be prepared to
adjust our approach as appropriate but
at the same time recognize that
individuals who are at higher risk will
need to take additional precautions for
themselves
those who are at lower risk again will
need to adjust based on their own risk
tolerance
and ultimately again i believe it is
absolutely critical that we work very
hard to
support a level of respectful dialogue
to help
ensure that the relationships in our
communities are strong because covet is
not the only significant issue that
we're facing together and
unfortunately over the last two years
there have been divisions that have
formed so i do think learning to live
with covet also means
learning to have those dialogues across
divisions
thanks dr hinshaw lauren follow up
i do thank you uh just an update dr
henshawn a question you were asked about
uh around the peak of the omicron wave
about the actual number of cases of the
virus since our pcr testing is so
limited and there are no plans to really
bring it back unless we need to with our
positivity rate hovering at around 20
how many cases do we likely have in the
province or how many are we catching
with testing
at that particular moment as you'll
recall i had estimated that we were
catching um
likely
around 1 in 10 was my estimate now
you'll recall that throughout most of
the pandemic based on our serology
results we estimate that we've caught
about one in four so it's not a new
reality that we've had more cases of
covet in the community than we've
diagnosed with our pcr program for many
reasons
often people are able to isolate at home
and they don't need to go in for testing
and that's fine so we were typically at
one and four moved to about one in six
for the delta wave based on our antibody
testing and and again i was estimating
in um in december that we were around
one in ten it
may have shifted to
be even more than 10 per individual case
diagnosed it's difficult to say
i haven't had a chance to look at the
the latest serology results in detail
but ultimately what i think is really
important for albertans to know is that
kovid is still out there and it is still
spreading so those who have risk factors
it's important for them to continue to
take precautions
at the same time the
prevalence the percent positivity has
come down that's about half of what it
was at the peak which is good news
continues to decline
so we will continue to watch that and
make sure that we are sharing
information that will help people to
make the risk-informed decisions
that
they're taking for their daily lives for
themselves and their loved ones
thanks dr hinshaw and minister copping
so that's it for today we'll see you
next week and of course between now and
then anyone with questions please feel
free to follow up with us separately so
thanks again